على راس 100 يوم كنا شهودا على حرب داميه
ومدمره بشكل لم يسبق له مثيل ولم تعشه غزه
ولم يمر على قطاع غزه كنا شهودا على ضمار
البيوت ضمار المربعات السكنيه وازالتها عن
الوجود شطب اسر وعائلات باكملها من السجل
المدني عشنا تجربه مستشفى الشفاء بمدينه
غزه الاشلاء والجثمان والضح
والاطفال والكبار والصغار والنساء والرجال
وكنا شهودا على حاله النزوح وحاله الهجره
القصريه كنا شهودا على كل هذه الماسي ولكن
مع الاسف كنا شهودا وتجرع مراره الاستهداف
الشخصي في هذه الحرب عندما استهدفت اسرتي
وذهبت نتيجه هذا الاستهداف زوجتي وابني
محمود وبنتي شا
فضلا عن استهداف المنزل وتدميره واستهداف
المكتب وتدميره وايضا استهدافي واصابت
واستشهاد الزميل سامر ابو دقه
وتتويجا استهداف ولد البكر حمزه والله
المستعان انا هشام زقوت من رفح جنوب قطع
غزه خلال 100 يوم من الحرب كنت شاهدا على
استهداف الاحتلال للصحفيين وع
المنازل على رؤوس ساكنيها شهدت القتل
والتدمير والتهجير والتجويع بفعل هذه
الحرب المستمره الاطفال والنساء هم جل
الضحايا مصابين تاره وشهداء تاره ومحاصرين
تحت انقاض منازلهم المدمره تارات اخرى حرب
ليست لها مثيل لكن تغطيتنا رغم كل المصاعب
والظروف
ستبقى
مستمره 100 يوم من الصبر والصمود لاكثر من
مليوني نسمه يعيشون تحت وطاه الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه 100 يوم على حرب لا تشبه
مثيلاتها من الحروب السابقه رغم تراجيديا
الالم التي تعتصر قلوبنا فقدنا الاهل
والزملاء والاصدقاء لكن تغطيتنا على شاشه
الجزيره لم تتوقف الحرب ليست مجرد ارقام
هي نهايات قصص واحلام وضعت لها حدا اله
الحرب الاسرائيليه الامل لدينا بغد مشرق
وبمستقبل افضل لاطفال غزه بعد ان تضع هذه
الحرب اوزارها انا الصحفي هاني الشاعر من
مدينه رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه متعاون مع قناه
الجزيره على مدار نحو 100 يوم من عمر
الحرب على قطاع غزه قمت بتغطيه هذه
الاباده الجماعيه مشاهد القتل مشاهد الالم
مشاهد الامل مشاهد ايضا الصمود والثبات
مشاهد القتل الجماعيه مشاهد قتل الابرياء
في الطرقات في مدارس الاواء في المنازل
السكنيه الامنه مشاهد نسف وتدمير مربعات
سكنيه مشاهد قتل الاطفال وقتل النساء
والاعتداء على المدارس والمشافي ومشاهد
التشرد والتجويع والموت حتى من قله الدواء
ومشاهد ايضا اغلاق المعابر من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه انا الصحفي اشرف ابو عمره من
المحافظه الوسطى من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
اعمل على تغطيه هذه الحرب منذ 100 يوم على
التوالي شاهدت مجازر اسرائيليه كبيره
وعمليه نزوح ايضا كبيره لم اشهدها من قبل
انا منذ 22 عاما وانا اعمل في هذا المجال
الصحفي هنا في قطاع غزه غطيت مجازر كبيره
بحق المدنيين الفلسطينيين والعائلات
الكامله التي ابيدت من السجل المدني هذه
المشاهد لم تفارقني ولو للحظه واحده هذه
الحرب حرب استثنائيه بكل ما تعني الكلمه
لي كصحفي فلسطيني اعمل على تغطيته هنا في
قطاع غزه لانها بالبدايه والنهايه ضد
المدنيين الفلسطينيين حسب ما شاهدنا
ووثقنا هنا في القطاع انا الصحفي اسماعيل
ابو عمر من خان يونس جنوب قطاع
غزه اغطي الان في محافظه خان يونس في
اليوم المئه من الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
شهدت مبتداها ويوم نصبت شراعها غطيت عديد
الاحداث عدوان الاحتلالي وصمود الشعب
الفلسطيني
ومقاومته وثقت كاميراتنا مشاهد التهجير
والنزوح واللجوء
وما فيها من تفاصيل معاناه كنا من البدايه
ولا تزال خطوط النهايه لم تنسج بعد